The Stephen King multiverse is vast so vast
that some diehard horror fans still haven't
fully explored it but we're going to do our
best.
Here's a brief explanation of the King multiverse,
from its origins to its various realities.
Stephen King's work now spans over 60 novels
and dozens of short stories, many of which
have been adapted to the screen in one form
or another.
His work has influenced pop culture in ways
that most authors only dream about.
"I'm your number one fan."
Throughout his work, King has created a full-fledged
multiverse.
This multiverse is touched upon mainly in
his Dark Tower novels — a saga that offers
a potentially limitless number of alternate
dimensions, pocket realities, and portals
between worlds.
Unfortunately, one of those worlds gave us
The Dark Tower film adaptation, but that's
a story for another time.
Sadly, there isn't a Stephen King novel that
clearly lays out every single aspect of this
multiverse... but a careful reader can slowly
start putting the pieces together.
The multiverse began with a darkness known
as the Prim.
From that Prim came a creator a being called
Gan whose name we first hear in The Dark Tower
series.
Hard to say what Gan looks like.
For our purposes, let's say Gan looks like
George Burns in Oh, God!
"I could even be a woman."
Gan is the creator of All-World, the reality
in which much of The Dark Tower saga takes
place.
But he's also the creator of all worlds, having
built the seemingly infinite planes of existence
that form King's multiverse.
He also created the Dark Tower, a massive
structure that exists physically in All-World
and symbolically in all dimensions, serving
as a linchpin for all of reality.
It's kind-of a big deal.
The plot thickens: In the final novel of the
Dark Tower series, the hero of the tale Roland
Deschain suspects the Dark Tower is actually
a physical manifestation of Gan.
That's certainly some food for thought.
We know that Stephen King is fond of setting
his stories in fictional towns… but are
places like Jerusalem's Lot and Castle Rock
connected to some larger fictional universe?
After all, some of his novels seem to be related
to one another in mysterious ways.
Remember when a character in The Dead Zone
mentions Carrie, Stephen King's first novel?
Well, in The Dark Tower series, King really
embraces the idea of multiple universes in
his work.
In fact, the more he worked on the saga, the
more he came to realize that much of his work
is connected in one way or another.
As he wrote in the foreword to the fourth
Dark Tower book, Wizard and Glass:
"I am coming to understand that Roland's world
(or worlds) actually contains all the others
of my making."
While writing the later volumes in his Dark
Tower series, King laid out a kind of cosmology
for these various worlds.
A great many of them connect or intersect,
with the Dark Tower novels serving as a kind
of nexus.
As Stephen King's body of work expanded, so
did his fictional multiverse.
In the realm of The Dark Tower, this multiverse
is vast enough to include potentially infinite
worlds, and that level of vastness means there
must be spaces between those worlds, too.
"Mid-world.
One-way destination."
King's novel It explores this idea further.
In fact, the book retroactively becomes part
of the Dark Tower multiverse and that's all
thanks to an ancient turtle spirit known as
Maturin.
Who knows what Maturin looks like?
For our purposes, let's say Maturin is a dead
ringer for Morla in The Neverending Story.
Anyway.
Maturin and the creature known as It both
originate from a place called the Macroverse,
which exists on a plane of reality outside
of Earth.
The Macroverse is home to a variety of powerful
entities, and it even helped spawn the universe
that contains King's more mainstream stories.
In the first Dark Tower novel The Gunslinger,
Roland meets a young boy named Jake Chambers,
who evidently arrived at All-World after dying
on his own version of Earth.
In The Drawing of the Three, the second Dark
Tower novel, Roland travels through a trio
of magical doors that allows him access to
that version of Earth, which has come to be
known as "Keystone Earth" in the larger Dark
Tower mythos.
"They're just like the quakes back home."
"Yeah, what happens in one world echoes in
others."
In the overarching story of The Dark Tower,
Keystone Earth is what we call the "real world."
Roland visits the real world at various times
and through the eyes of different people,
which helps him gain knowledge of our world
and how it works.
Many of Stephen King's stories seem to take
place on Earth — rather than, say, the Keystone
Earth of the Dark Tower novels.
We're thinking of novels like The Shining,
It, The Dead Zone, Carrie, and a bunch of
others.
Well, in The Dark Tower mythology, we learn
that Earth was apparently spawned by Maturin
the ancient turtle, who vomited up our planet
following a terrible stomach ache.
Interestingly, several not-so subtle references
in the Dark Tower books link the story to
a few of King's standalone novels... including
allusions to the monstrous Cujo and Misery's
Paul Sheldon.
Meanwhile, Danny Torrance quotes The Dark
Tower in the novel Doctor Sleep, the sequel
to The Shining.
And we should mention the idea of "shining"
is brought up in The Dark Tower film, too.
"His Shine is beyond anything I've ever seen."
There was a six-year gap between the publication
of the fourth Dark Tower novel, 1997's Wizard
and Glass, and the fifth novel in the series,
2003's Wolves of the Calla.
And there's a very good reason for that.
In 1999, Stephen King was struck by a van
while taking a walk near his home.
The accident almost killed him.
As he told The Bangor Daily News in 2014:
"I was in a lot of pain, and when you're in
that situation, you don't feel much like writing."
Following this near-death experience, King
decided to add a new layer of metafiction
to the Dark Tower mythos: He wrote himself
into the story as a fictional character — a
mind-blowing move.
In the sixth Dark Tower novel, Song of Susannah,
Roland actually meets Stephen King.
We soon learn that King is feeding Roland
the knowledge he needs to complete his quest.
And if this version of Stephen King dies,
Roland's quest will end in failure.
Out of all the film and TV adaptations of
Stephen King's work, only The Dark Tower and
Castle Rock have really embraced the idea
of a multiverse.
In The Dark Tower film, plenty of characters
take jaunts between All-World and Keystone
Earth.
And in the first season of Castle Rock, the
show introduces the multiverse as a key concept.
It seems as though the TV version of Castle
Rock exists in some alternate reality that's
distinct from the Castle Rock featured in
novels like The Dead Zone.
One thing we know for sure: As long as Stephen
King keeps writing, his multiverse will continue
to expand, offering us plenty of alternate
realities to explore.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.